[Musique]
avec l' annonce du déconfinement
progressif à partir du 11 mai se pose la
question de la sécurité sanitaire de
tous les français
et parmi les solutions évoquées par le
gouvernement pour s'assurer qu'une
deuxième vague de l'épidémie ne touchera
pas la france celle du tracking par
téléphone mobile une mesure très
contestée par de nombreux français qui
ont peur que cette localisation en temps
réel des citoyens par l'état devienne à
long terme une méthode pour contrôler
les masses et priver les gens de liberté
même en interne chez la république en
marche le débat fait rage
face à cette défiance le gouvernement a
décidé de faire trancher la question par
le parlement une façon de débattre de la
question et le cas échéant d'en définir
les application baptisée stop qu'ovide
cette application qui pourrait devenir
obligatoire pour chaque français
utilisent la géolocalisation du
téléphone pour enregistrer toutes les
personnes avec qui chacun entre en
contact si une personne est ensuite
détecter positivo qu'ovide 19 une
notification est envoyé à tous les
individus entrés en contact avec le
malade pour les prévenir et qu'ils
puissent prendre les mesures nécessaires
pour s'isoler et se faire eux aussi
dépister un programme géant de traçage
de la population qui fait débat dans de
nombreux pays alors l'application de
tracking bientôt votée à l'assemblée
bonne ou mauvaise idée
[Musique]
mounir mahjoubi qui est avec nous
députés la république en marche et
ancien secrétaire d'état au numérique
merci d'être là mounir merci beaucoup
qui est également confiné mais vous avez
vu voilà mounir mahjoubi c'est pas comme
nous quand il est confiné voyait là des
bouquins derrière lui on voit que c'est
quelqu'un qui étudient il ya comme
matthieu delormeau et lui qu'il étudie
nous on est voilà on est reconnaissante
mounir merci d'être avec nous parce que
c'est vrai que beaucoup de français
s'inquiètent de l'arrivée prochaine de
cette application
1 voilà c'est vrai que ici par exemple
c'est très partagés ici il ya mathieu
delormeau je crois qui est pour et il ya
gilles verdez qui couvre au labour il ya
il est pur aussi jean séguy c'est que
castaldi qui compte parce que il a peur
d'être traqué mounir qu'est ce que
pourrait dire aux gens qui ont peur
d'être traqué qui lisent cette
application c'est vraiment s'immiscer
encore plus dans notre vie bon ça c'est
vraiment ça tout ça me fait très plaisir
de vous retrouver
alors cette appli faut d'abord se dire
de quoi on parle parce que le mot
tracking ça peut faire un peu peur mais
on peut croire que c'est sur mon
téléphone sonne une application qui va
me suivre partout je suis qui va envoyer
au gouvernement en permanence ma
position que ça pourrait être utilisé
contre moi dans l'application dont il
s'agit là c'est ce qu'on appelle le
traçage de contact alors que ça
correspond à quoi la jenny mohamed il
n'est plus là mais
on peut le dire c'est en phase 1 et 2 à
chaque fois qu'une personne qui est
testée positive sans téléphone sans
technologie elle subit un interrogatoire
vous savez en stade 1 et 2 quand
quelqu'un va être testé positif on va
lui demander jeudi vous étiez ou de 13 à
14 vous étiez assis face à elle ou à
côté d'elle
vous êtes resté cinq minutes 10 minutes
ou une heure et en fait ces inspecteurs
de la rs là il faut déjà ça il faisait
des halles 107 1 et 2 en stade 3 pas
parce qu'à trop de malades mais
découvrons viendra au stade 2 on le fera
et en fait on vous fait sur un papier
alors à leur mode artisanal le décompte
de tous les gens que vous avez peut-être
infectés pourquoi pour vous puissiez les
prévenir et pour que se protège et
deviennent pas des personnes qui vont
infecter d'autres personnes et bien
l'application que le gouvernement
propose c'est une application qui sera
scindé moyen parmi les autres en plus
des masses en plus des tests en plus des
mesures de sécurité qui va permettre de
retrouver tous les gens qu'on a
peut-être qu'on terminée est-ce que
honnêtement moi à titre personnel j'ai
envie de savoir qui j'ai plus profond
terminé j'ai envie de leur dire ma
famille c'est facile parce que je sais
que j'étais avec eux tout âge
je vais les prévenir mes voisins aussi
je mets prévenir cette ligne sonne avec
qui j'ai parlé mardi dernier je vais pas
m'en souvenir
eh bien je serai content qu'elle fume
aident à le faire alors nous il faisait
sûr que c'est que le sujet divise on a
même retrouvé une intervention du
ministre de la santé à l'assemblée
nationale qui date de fin mars
et regardez ce qu'il disait sur le
cracking regarde la corée c'est ce qu'on
appelle du tracking la corée à équiper
tous les téléphones et les données
personnelles de ce qui était nécessaire
pour prévenir tout l'entourage
lorsqu'une personne était malade
est ce que vous êtes très à suivre la
corée jusqu'au bout de sa démarche moi
je n'en suis pas convaincu et à titre
personnel je vous le dis non plus voilà
alors à l'époque il n'était pas
convaincu donc mounir il a raison il
parle pas de la même chose
il parle de d'accord entre elles le
tracking complet vous savez ce qu'il
faut en corée du sud quand même on vous
demande pas votre avis l'application
elle n'est pas volontaire
l'application elle n'est pas juste en
bluetooth pour savoir qui vous avez
croisé encore aider vous êtes positif si
vous êtes un étranger qui arrive et en
corée s'ils demandent à tous les
opérateurs téléphoniques toutes les
informations sur vous tous les
informations carte bleue elles sont
toutes réunies dans une méga base de
données à partir de cette méga base de
données ils ont des algorithmes qui
essaie d'identifier quand est ce que
vous avez pu potentiellement croisé
cette personne dès que vous bougez vous
avez une a l'air si vous respectez pas
le confinement
une alerte et vous avez la police qui
peut intervenir sa personne ça va être
votée à l'assemblée parce que même au
sein du gouvernement même au sein des
deux voies de la république en marche
mine de rien au sein du parti du
gouvernement et bien il y en a qui sont
contre c'est le cas de guillaume chiche
regard des députés voilà la république
en marge des deux sèvres qui est
totalement contre ce projet regardez ce
qu'ils disent est organisé le ciblage
des personnes atteintes par le coc u19
pour en faire un signalement à leur
entourage social c'est ouvrir la voie à
une ségrégation et à l'exclusion des
personnes contaminées
la première étape c'est quoi on prévient
les personnes avec qui vous avez été en
contact et la seconde c'est on vous
empêche de vous rendre au supermarché je
crois que ce n'est pas acceptable
par ailleurs je me pose la question de
qui aura accès à cette application moi
je suis élu d'un département rural des
deux sèvres où les zones blanches existe
toujours et c'est un enjeu majeur
toute la population n'est pas équipé en
smartphones nous en montre connectés qui
se retrouveraient exclu d'un tel
dispositif que leur dit on alors voyons
pas donc quelques d'ongame chiche qui
était parti de la république en mars
aussi ce député est contre mounir donc
c'est pour ça que ça va être voté aussi
à l'assemblée parce que ça divise
énormément moi je trouve ça très bien
que les gens s'approprient le débat que
les gens posent les questions mais par
exemple sur quatre points
je viens de relever guillaume chiche les
quatre soins le gouvernement apporte une
réponse je vais 4 pour lui a dit vous
avez raison de les souligner ce serait
très grave si ça faisait ça et ça n'est
pas le cas mais vous savez il ya deux
propositions qui passent pas par le
téléphone mobile qu'il faut aussi un peu
sursauter les personnes je sais pas si
vous avez entendu la mère de paris par
exemple a proposé le certificat de
positivité pour avoir le droit de
reprendre le travail ça malheureusement
ce sera peut-être un des seuls objets
qu'on sera obligé d'utiliser mais ça va
quand même dire que si on a un
certificat en page sur l' on passe pas
exactement
matthieu delormeau qu'est ce que vous en
pensez mathias je suis subjugué de
devoir systématiquement dans ce pays
comme on est trop même débattre sur
n'importe quoi les bobos dans les cafés
parisiens qui parlent de liberté parce
qu'ils n'ont pas compris ce sujet on ne
parle pas de la corée ou des pays ou des
émirats où on prend toutes vos données
dans votre téléphone pour savoir si vous
êtes homosexuel 2
gauche de droite et tout ça c'est pas du
tout le but c'est au contraire pour ceux
qui ont pris le temps de lire et de
comprendre avant de râler c'est une
application de craie vention ya pas de
ségrégation
c'est de la prévention je ne comprends
même pas qu'on puisse en débattre à
l'assemblée et comme toujours dans ce
pays
perdre des semaines et des semaines à
parler dans le vide pour faire quelque
chose que d'autres pays vont faire bien
avant nous et prendre de l'avancé parce
qu'au final on retient par le faire
c'est fou quand même
laurent chevallier déjà on en débat à
l'assemblée c'est quand même la moindre
des choses parce qu'on était plus dit
représentent les français et c'est
normal que les français les ai quand
même leur mot à dire par le biais de
leurs députés nouveau delà de ça c'est
pas le problème de la privation des
libertés ou du pistage c'est que au delà
des propos de même venir mahdjoubi moi
j'ai lu tout ce qui pouvait exister sur
le sujet je ne vois pas en quoi ça va
être efficace
concrètement vous allez je bien compris
le système recevoir un message comme
quoi vous avez croisé dans la journée
quelqu'un qui a été contaminé plus ou
moins donc
et qu'est ce qui va se passer alors vous
imaginez on va reprendre les transports
en commun à partir du 11 mai évidemment
que dans une vie normale d'une journée
normale vous allez croiser quelqu'un qui
va être contaminé et qu'est ce qui va se
passer vous allez recevoir un message
sur votre téléphone et dont vous faites
quoi du coup vous enlevez votre enfant
de l'école vous l'amener plus vous
arrêter de travailler que ce qu'on avait
reçu ce message c'est ce qui va se
passer en dans un second temps une fois
pour reçoit ce message alors mounir
jusque là la réponse là dessus
laurence cette question elle s'applique
avec ou sans application parce que je
voulais dit tout à l'heure
quoi qu'il arrive à chaque fois que vous
serez positif la personne elle va subir
un interrogatoire et va donner la liste
de vingt trente personnes qu'elle a
croisées
qu'est ce qu'elles font ces 20 à 30
personnes on fera la même chose pour le
monde physique que pour cette
application virtuelle l'appli elle
change rien le fonds s'est rapidement
selon lapierre à l'assemblée nationale
on était un des premiers avec le stuff
quand on était parmi les gens qui
étaient en contact d'une personne
eh ben on est resté chez nos quatorze
jours d'accord alors on va voir ce qu'on
pense les téléspectateurs me ans
laurence voilà on va voir le sondage
qu'est ce qu'ils en pensent les 1000
spectateurs bonne idée à 36% mauvaises
idées à 64%
l'application de tracking bientôt votée
à l'assemblée 64% nos téléspectateurs
pense que c'est une mauvaise idée on
verra en tout cas le résultat d'hier a
expliqué syrie
mal expliqué mal compris je pense et ben
écoutez en tout cas ça sera voté à
l'assemblée on verra le résultat